(breathing heavily)
- It's not a race.
- Hey guys.
Game night at my house tonight.
Coming?
- I have to go to the gym.
Hey dude.
Great job on that project.
It was so good.
- Why?
- Girl, what's with your lunch?
- I have to eat a certain amount of macros
with every meal.
So, there's macro nutrients
and micro nutrients.
Micro nutrients are like your vitamins.
- Hey, Joy.
Wanna fry?
- No.
- Here we go guys.
Just a few more miles.
I eat a certain amount of
each one with every meal.
So I need 18 grams of protein.
That's why I have the chicken.
And then I need vegetables
with every meal.
- Wanna hand out on Saturday with me?
- I have to go to the gym.
- All day?
- Let's have a lazy weekend.
- Yeah, with Netflix and pizza.
- No. I think we should go on a hike.
We need to get outside
and move our bodies.
Burn some calories.
Sweat a little bit.
Here we go guys.
A couple more sets.
Squeeze those abs.
Chest to knees.
- Oh, God.
This hurts so much.
- You got it.
Nice work.
- My abs.
- Just embrace the pain.
- So tough.
- We'll be done soon.
- I don't know if I can do anymore.
- You guys are doing great work.
(laughs)